(audience applauds)
- All right, everybody, we are back.
And our next guest is
truly multi-talented.
She played Regina George
in the Broadway production
of "Mean Girls."
You've seen her in the HBO Max series,
"The Sex Lives of College Girls."
Now she's put out her very first EP
which promises to have a song to suit
whatever mood you are in.
Now performing "Too Well"
off her EP "Everything To Everyone,"
give it up for Reneé Rapp.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(lighthearted piano music)
♪ Today I woke up in
a good mood for once ♪
♪ First time in six months,
I don't hate you as much ♪
♪ You weren't there in my
dreams, I could finally sleep ♪
♪ It felt good, but it sucks,
I don't hate you as much ♪
♪ It's easier holdin' a grudge ♪
♪ I'd rather be angry than crushed ♪
♪ I'm doin' too much ♪
♪ I'm back where I started again ♪
♪ Cryin' and callin' my friends ♪
♪ Never ends ♪
♪ I get so sick of myself ♪
♪ Can't stop overthinkin' ♪
♪ I heard you're happy somewhere else ♪
♪ But I don't forget too well ♪
♪ I get so sick of myself ♪
♪ Can't stop reminiscin' ♪
♪ I heard you're happy somewhere else ♪
♪ But I don't forget too well ♪
♪ I still see your face,
I hate hearin' your name ♪
♪ What a wreck, what a shame,
I'm replayin' that day ♪
♪ You called me at 8:00,
two weeks on a break ♪
♪ Just to ask for more space,
you're my biggest mistake ♪
♪ It's easier holdin' a grudge ♪
♪ I'd rather be angry than crushed ♪
♪ I'm doin' too much ♪
♪ I'm back where I started again ♪
♪ Cryin' and callin' my friends ♪
♪ Never ends, ugh ♪
♪ I get so sick of myself ♪
♪ Can't stop overthinkin' ♪
♪ I heard you're happy somewhere else ♪
♪ But I don't forget too well ♪
♪ I get so sick of myself, ♪
♪ Can't stop reminiscin' ♪
♪ I heard you're happy somewhere else ♪
♪ But I don't forget too well ♪
♪ I get so sick of myself ♪
♪ Can't stop overthinkin' ♪
♪ I heard you're happy somewhere else ♪
♪ But I don't forget too well ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
- All right, one more time,
give it up for Reneé Rapp, everybody.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Her debut EP "Everything
To Everyone" is out now,
so go get yourself a copy.